in some of my previous episodes i have
mentioned in passing
hermes and hermeticism as these are
topics that often pop up in various
places and that have played an important
role in the history of religion and
philosophy
but as important as they are not too
many people know what these words
actually denote you may think of
hermeticism as something esoteric
connected to the occult sciences into
things like
magic for example or maybe you
rightfully associate the name hermes
with the greek god who goes by that name
hermeticism is a topic that has
interested philosophers mystics and
scholars throughout the centuries from
proclass to
muslim philosophers like eben sabain and
the israelis safa
to marcilio ficino and that one
spiritual aunt who everyone in the
family thinks is kind of weird
but how much has hermeticism actually
influenced the history of religion
turns out quite a lot actually which
gives me good reason to dedicate a full
episode to discussing this very
fascinating subject
so what is hermeticism
[Applause]
i have again chosen to join forces with
my friend dr justin sledge on the
channel esoterica
to give you a double feature this time
about hermeticism
in this video i'll be talking more
generally about the origins and
philosophical ideas of hermeticism and
dr sledge
in his video on his channel will be
talking specifically about the
emerald tablet which is a fascinating
hermetic text
so please after you watch this one go
check out his video and also subscribe
to his channel it's a wonderful
wonderful channel
hermeticism is first and foremost a
mystical
called religious and philosophical
movements
connected to an ancient collection of
writings and their supposed author
hermes tris megistas it is a tradition
that dates back primarily to late
antiquity in a greco-egyptian
environment but that has had a major
influence on
various different cultures religions and
esoteric communities throughout history
since then
the central figure of this general trend
hermes
is an elusive figure one to whom a
number of different
legends and mythical stories are
attributed
but what we can be sure about is that
hermes tris megistas in this particular
manifestation
and the movement and literature we
usually refer to as hermetic
originates in egypt during the time of
hellenistic and roman occupation
we're talking roughly between the
conquest of alexander the great in the
late 4th century bc
to the 4th century ce or a d
depending on what word you want to use
this was an environment where the
hellenistic culture which had origins in
greece mingled and interacted with the
native egyptian culture and nowhere was
this more visible perhaps
than in the sphere of religion while the
native egyptians themselves were
sometimes very hostile to religious and
cultural syncretism
the influence of greek language
philosophy and religion became an
inescapable reality
the hellenistic leaders themselves often
chose to syncretize their own religious
background
with the cults of egypt and this created
some very interesting developments
in this process many gods from the greek
context were merged with egyptian
deities
gods who shared attributes or functions
could be seen as the same god
but with different names and they were
as i just said sometimes also
merged together and one such synthesis
was made between the greek god hermes
and the egyptian toth toth was one of
the most popular deities in the egyptian
pantheon
he was associated with the ibis bird and
is indeed usually depicted with an
ibis's head
toth served many different functions he
was the god of
writing the scribe and the messenger of
the gods
he was the god of wisdom one who
invented the art of
writing and the hieroglyphs composer of
sacred literature like the book of the
dead
and the source of all occult and
esoteric
knowledge the god hermes of the greek
pantheon
served a quite similar role and the two
quickly started to be associated with
each other
eventually resulting in the merged
character or god
of hermes tris megistas tris magustus
meaning
thrice greats and probably originates
from an epithet for
toth this character became associated
with many different
legends and traditions there are many
different accounts about hermes and who
he was but
many of them considered him to have been
human at some point
or at least to have lived among humans
and in very ancient
times this human hermes is thought to
have reached a kind of illumination and
ascended to the world of the divine
certainly a divine figure at the very
least hermes was considered to have been
the originator of many religious and
philosophical traditions
some claimed he was the teacher of moses
or that of pythagoras
and that his wisdom has been carried
down in different lines through great
figures like plato for example
the jewish historian artapinus of
alexandria who lived in the 2nd century
bc
even identified hermes with moses
outright
these various legends can be complicated
and sometimes seem contradictory
the toth of egyptian religion was
clearly a distant and
all-knowing abstract god while the
hermes of greece had a more human
background which
probably resulted in these varying
accounts some chroniclers including the
egyptian priest manathoe
even consider there to have been
multiple hermeses it all gets very
confusing and we're not going to dwell
on the
mythological character and legends
around the figure of hermes himself
that will have to be saved for a later
episode but what is important
or or what is relevant to know at this
point is that sometime
in antiquity there appeared many
different writings a corpus of writings
that was attributed to
the figure of hermes considered to have
been written
by this figure hermes often considered
to have been the originator of
philosophy alchemy magic and astrology
appears as author of a huge corpus of
texts
as a general term the wider collection
of text attributed to him
is known as the hermetica and when we
talk about the hermetic texts
they are often divided into two general
categories
the technical hermetica and the
philosophical hermetica
the former the technical hermetica
consists of the majority of the texts
dealing with such topics as magic
astrology divination
alchemy and other occult sciences while
the latter the
philosophical hermetica being more
speculative and philosophical in nature
thus having a rather different approach
it is important to remember however that
when we divide the
hermetic literature into these general
categories of technical and
philosophical
we are kind of creating or
anachronistically
dividing the literature into categories
that the ancients or
people of antiquity themselves probably
wouldn't have
conceived the early hermitis or readers
of this literature
probably wouldn't have divided the
literature into these wider categories
but i think these categorization can
still be useful
today it helps us navigate through a
complex world of ancient literature
as mentioned the technical hermetica
make up the
bulk of the material because indeed
hermes was
primarily associated or seen as the
father or
originator of occult sciences like magic
and especially astrology just like
toth was always seen in earlier egyptian
religion
hermes was the arch esotericist
the source of wisdom and hidden
knowledge
indeed in the greek magical papyri it is
said about hermes that he knows quotes
all that is hidden under the heavenly
vault
and beneath the earth this very strong
association of hermes with the occult
survived for
long after the texts were supposedly
written
far into the islamic period and into
renaissance europe and beyond
now even though the hermitis of
antiquity probably conceived of all of
these texts as actually being written
by the sage or god or whatever you want
to call him hermes tris megistas
scholars today of course have a rather
different perspective on it since
hermes let's face it is most likely a
mythical figure
thus the dating of these texts is an
often debated and discussed matter
but the usual dating is that the larger
corpus was composed
from around a century to bc to around
300 or 400 a.d
the technical hermetica is often
considered to be the oldest at least
certain parts of it
perhaps dating to periods before the
common era a few centuries before
bc whereas the philosophical hermetica
is usually considered to be
later compositions likely in the second
to third centuries a.d
the most famous of the philosophical
writings the so-called corpus hermeticum
was most likely composed in 2nd century
alexandria
a melting pot of intellectual religious
and cultural activity
it was the zenith of hellenistic and
roman rule in
egypt and the corpus hermeticum among
other texts
most likely emerges in this very
syncretistic
environment while it is somewhat
anachronistic to divide the literature
into the technical and philosophical
categories
it does seem that the philosophical
writings were often viewed as distinct
and as forming a kind of unified whole
even to people of antiquity
references to the philosophical
hermetica often group together many of
these texts as
representing some kind of unified
movement
and we can thus assume that much of this
literature is the result of a
somewhat coherent group or general
movement that existed in antiquity
probably in or around alexandria in
egypt
the corpus hermeticum is perhaps the
most prominent and famous production of
these hermitis
it consists of 18 separate treatises
talking about the individual soul and
its potential ascent to the world of the
divine
noose or mind or intellect through
what's known as gnosis
but the text that reaches does so
through several filters
the collection of the corpus in
particular was a compilation of
byzantine christian editors in the
middle ages
the earliest attestation we have of the
corpus is in the writings of michael
selles in the 11th century
the christian editors of these texts
most likely did some editing
leaving out sections of text that were
too pagan in nature and leaving in only
those acceptable to
perceived christian orthodoxy in other
words the philosophical hermetica that
does survive
like the corpus hermeticum for example
probably does so
because of these later compilations and
the fact that they were deemed
acceptable
in contrast to other parts of the
literature that is sadly lost to time
but the hermetica that does survive is
still very much significant
despite the fact that they were edited
by later scholars
the text paints a lively picture of the
cosmos and its relationship to god
and it probably functioned primarily as
an aid in
spiritual development for individuals
who were
initiated into the hermetic secrets
aside from the most famous corpus
hermeticum
the other philosophical hermetica that
survives include the latin asclepius
known originally in greek as the perfect
discourse
there is also the definitions of her
mischievous megistas to asclepius
sometimes known as the armenian
definitions due to its surviving only an
armenian manuscript there's also the
compilations and excerpts of stobius
of the fifth century called the stobayan
excerpts
as well as a very significant section
found in nag hamadi
including the fascinating discourse on
the ogdo ad and the any ad
even though these texts are different in
some respects and can seemingly even
contradict themselves in some places
we'll return to this later they all seem
to be the production
of the same hermetic quote unquote
movement of intellectual slash religious
current in late antiquity
indeed the famous late platonist
philosopher iamblicus
speaks about a court way of hermes
indicating a certain path that was
associated with these hermetic texts
but what do these texts actually say as
already mentioned the texts and
philosophy of the
philosophical hermetica were probably
part of
an initiatory group of spiritual
aspirants although there are
certain scholars today that question
this idea and are skeptical towards it
due to a lack of evidence which is
understandable there are
different opinions about whether or not
this is true now most of these texts
including indeed the corpus hermeticum
take the form of you could call it
teaching sessions so
one-on-one sessions where a teacher
discloses
knowledge to a student the teacher in
most cases being
hermes himself while the student is one
of the other
recurring characters of the hermetica
characters like
asclepius and tot but on some occasions
this trend is broken
a prominent example is in the very first
treatise of the corpus hermeticum known
as the poi mandrus
in which hermes is the one being taught
by this other character called
poemandres which the treatise is named
after
and this character poemandus is
identified in the text
as the noos the divine noose now nos is
a word that is basically impossible to
translate but
it is usually rendered as the intellect
or as the divine
mind already we get a glimpse into the
exalted and complex religious
philosophical worlds of the hermetica
or the philosophical america to be exact
the texts were again probably used
as spiritual aid for people who were
initiated into this hermetic
group although again some scholars will
doubt this idea
and these initiates were probably being
led by a spiritual guide
much like in the text themselves it
seems that
if there was this initiatory hermetic
group the teacher-student relationship
seems to have played a very important
role
which is then reflected in the text
themselves the teacher
would have been a very important factor
in the
spiritual ascent of the student
towards the divine world this would have
been central to the quote-unquote way of
hermes
that people like yamblicus spoke of the
metaphysics and cosmology that the texts
present is a colorful one
at its center is god who is one and the
creator of all things
god is sometimes called the father in
the text and the general attitude
towards god is
significantly more devotional and
personal than for example in the later
neoplatonic
writings of platinus aside from god the
hermitis then divide reality into
various spheres
there's god again there's the
intelligible world the physical world
and the human being in a kind of
descending order the human being however
is the microcosm of creation and thus
at least in his spiritual or noetic
intellectual reality
is exalted above other inhabitants of
the cosmos
including even lesser deities and gods
this idea of the human being as a
microcosm of the
larger macrocosm of the universe or
divine world is a theme that will recur
continuously in history and even outside
of hermeticism as well
aside from this the system also includes
various planetary spheres
diamonds and divinities fitting for a
late antique philosophical environment
but even though they seem to divide the
world into a hierarchy of sorts
this entire cosmos is intimately
interconnected and united in
sympathea everything in the world is
connected and interacts in other words
this is an idea that is probably taken
from the stoics
indeed the hermitis present a monistic
picture of reality
where everything is a divine unity in
the words of the scholar garth
fouden quote thus everything is part of
god
and god is in everything his creative
activity continuing unceasingly
all things are one and the pleiroma of
being is indestructible
despite this the human being is
especially exalted as having a divine
spark or
in a sense being divine in nature at
least more so than other
things the soul of the human being can
ascend through this hierarchy of being
to reach communion with the divine noose
and with god himself
it is with this that the philosophical
hermetica is primarily concerned
the texts were again most likely part of
an initiatory spiritual practice that
aimed to purify the soul of
impurity to shed attachment and
connection to the body and the world of
matter
and to ascend to become unified and
assimilated into the one god
so that the person himself becomes
divine it seems that the hermetic
practices included a kind of asceticism
but not to any extreme degree we don't
find the kind of world
neglecting negative attitudes of the
gnostics
for example in these texts well actually
sometimes we do
it's complicated indeed many scholars
have pointed out and
if you read the text you will probably
see yourself that the texts
aren't always that consistent in its
expressions
sometimes the material world the
physical world is
seen as a beautiful manifestation or
expression of god or
and of divinity a world that is worthy
of being
admired and of being studied and then in
other texts the world is seen as a
negative prison that is to be escaped
entirely
for example in the asclepius or perfect
discourse
sex the sexual act is praised as a great
pleasure and a
mirroring of the creative act of god and
in parts of the corpus
the text suggests that one should
definitely have children for example
quote
prudent people therefore regard the
making of children as a duty in life to
be taken most
seriously and greatly revered and should
any human being pass away
childless they see it as the worst
misfortune and irreverence
but in other treatises of the corpus we
are presented with the opposite image
with sex being considered a great curse
similarly the vision of reality seems to
change across treatises as well
in some sections we are presented with a
monistic philosophy
with all of reality being one and god
being identified with the all
the physical world is thus a beautiful
manifestation of this god quote
for there is nothing in all the cosmos
that he is not
he is himself the things that are and
those that are not
those that are he has made visible those
that are not he holds within him
this is the god who is greater than any
name this is the god invisible and
entirely visible
this god who is evident to the eyes may
be seen in the mind
he is bodiless and many-bodied or rather
he is all-bodied
there is nothing that he is not for he
also is all that is
and this is why he has all names because
they are of one father
and this is why he has no name because
he is father of them all
but on the other hand again in other
treatises or sections
the picture is a lot more dualistic with
the world being seen as the opposite of
god
and it's a kind of curse or a kind of
prison that is to be escaped
so what's up with these paradoxical
statements
scholars previously and some today have
argued that because of these great
contradictions in the text
this must mean that the different
treatises of the text
were probably written by different
groups altogether so different people
with different philosophical outlooks
and they were only sort of grouped
together into a single corpus
at a later date however many today have
taken a different route in interpreting
these texts and the
seemingly paradoxical statements within
them the scholar garth fowden argues
that this diversity of perspectives
is not the result of different outlooks
philosophically
but instead represent the gradual
development and ascent
of the spiritual initiate in other words
some of the treatises are meant for a
person in the early stages of spiritual
development
and present one view of reality in the
world while others
like the heavily abstract progress are
aimed at more advanced students
who have reached a higher state of
purification
because indeed the hermitis were
concerned with two different kinds of
knowledge
what they called episteme and gnosis
the former category episteme is the
product of reason
and consists of all forms of exterior or
conceptual knowledge of things
graspable to the mind the latter
gnosis is the product of a different
kind of understanding
a direct ineffable non-conceptual
experience of the truth through
spiritual insight
and what gnosis of god and one's own
true nature
is clearly the goal for the hermitis
episteme or knowledge of the world
is also very important to know god we
must first know creation through
studying it
as the corpus itself puts it quote
gnosis is the goal
of episteme or in these tourbillon
fragments quote
without philosophy it is impossible to
be perfectly pious
he who learns of what nature things are
and how they are ordered and by whom and
to what end
will be thankful for all things to the
creator and to a good father
a kindly foster and a faithful guardian
he who is thankful will be a pious man
and the pious man will know where and
what
truth is and through this knowledge will
become still more
pious this is why the beauty and
nobility of the physical world
is emphasized in many of the treatises
this perspective
is an important step on the way however
once the practitioner reaches a higher
stage of development and ideally of
gnosis he can transcend this perspective
as he sheds his connection to the world
of matter and form
and when the soul ascends enough to
reach perfect gnosis
he will be reborn not in a physical
sense of course but in a spiritual sense
he will become one with the noose the
divine mind
and with god himself transforming his
soul into a divine status
this is just a simplified walkthrough of
the contents of the philosophical
hermetica
but it gives you a pretty good idea of
some recurring themes and
features that it is known for and which
would become
so influential in later times in
different
religious and philosophical currents
indeed while we know very little about
the actual people who wrote
the hermetica these texts
and nothing of their so-called movement
survives
today still the techs themselves had
incredible staying power
across history and across a diverse
array of different circumstances and
contexts in religious
and philosophical environments hermes
was a powerful name and figure who
continued to be revered in different
forms in different religions
but always with a strong association to
the occult
to astrology and alchemy some of the
early church fathers of christianity
like clement of alexandria
seems to have read the text and
considered hermes a great teacher of the
world's wisdoms
it also became important for later
philosophers like the late platonist the
amplicus and proclass
and for alchemists like sozimos of
panopoulos
after the arrival of islam and the
islamic civilization
hermes and hermeticism or hermetism
continued to influence religious and
philosophical currents in this context
as well
hermes was often identified with the
quranic prophet idris
and the biblical enoch and thus seen as
one of the great messengers of god and
originator of hidden wisdoms
from early philosophers like al-kindi
and abu mashar in baghdad
to the world of medieval andalusia and
sufi philosophers like ibn sabain and
al-shushtali
hermes and the teachings associated with
him continue to be very influential
in the islamic world in the great arabic
sufi poet al-shushtali's poem known as
the
crasada nunea in other words the old
rhyming in the letter
noon he lists some of his great
spiritual teachers and forebearers
and includes names like plato aristotle
and indeed hermes which text in
particular these people had access to
and thus which ideas they picked up and
from where is hard to say for sure
but hermeticism got a serious shot in
the arm in europe
in the 15th century when the corpus
hermeticum was rediscovered
and translated for the first time into
latin by marcelio ficino
hermes and the hermetica would be seen
both in later europe and earlier in
the medieval islamic world as very
ancient
and as the originator of teachings
inherited by people like
moses and the great prophets as well as
philosophers of history
the hermetica had an enormous impact on
the world of western esotericism
from that point and even to this very
day hermeticism today can be a lot of
different things it is often very
loosely connected to
any general esoteric wisdom or occult
knowledge
but it all stems back to the ancient
collection of texts
that is attributed to the figure of
hermes just megistas
today we know that the text most likely
didn't originate with hermes himself and
that the stories about him and his role
in history of philosophy and religion
is probably mythical but that doesn't
change the fact that the hermetic
literature has been immensely
influential
and played a central role in the history
of esotericism
occultism as well as religion mysticism
and philosophy in general
much of what we associate with occult
sciences
magic astrology and alchemy is very
strongly connected to
the hermetic tradition all these various
topics and incarnations of the figure of
hermes across
history and different cultures there's
all the serbs videos of their own but
in this video i have attempted to give a
general outlook
of the basic hermetic texts and the
movement
in which those texts emerge and a little
bit about
how those texts have influenced later
religious and philosophical currents as
well
hermes just megistas the toth of
egyptian religion
continues to exert his mystical
influence upon us
the vast body of literature attributed
to him serves as one of the treasures of
intellectual history
as a part of our collective heritage
that isn't always given its due
even though it has played such a major
role now given the topic of this video
it was only natural that this was to be
another collaboration with my good
friend
dr justin sledge from the channel
esoterica
dr sledge is an expert on all things
hermeticism he has studied these topics
for many many years and his
amazing channel esoterica deals
primarily
with what he calls the arcane side of
history philosophy and religion
i cannot recommend his channel enough
especially for topics like this
his companion video to this one will be
dealing with the emerald tablet one of
the most famous
texts from the wider hermetic corpus
so please go check out that video and go
subscribe to his channel if you haven't
already
it really is so so great and you will
gain a lot of benefits from watching his
videos
this video as always is brought to you
by our patrons
i would like to give a special shout out
to the new saint larry hughes
and a thank you to all of you who keep
supporting me monetarily it really is
making all the difference
in me being able to give you free
content
that is both academic and scholarly
based
i really appreciate it thank you all so
so much
look forward to more content related to
this in the future as there is so much
to
cover here and so much interesting stuff
so look forward to that in the future
thank you all for watching i hope you
enjoyed the video if you want to support
the channel
you can like subscribe and comment on
the video
you can also become a patron i will
leave a link to
our patreon page in the description you
can also leave a one-time donation
through
paypal i look forward to seeing your
opinions in the comments and to continue
this discussion with you in various ways
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you